I'm Ryan and I'm grace hat way now he  was kind of a flirt hi I'm Emily I play  Natalie on gilt any of your shady crap  blows back on her I will make you pay  don't miss this week's episode the  second one it's called hashtag American  Psycho oh my god look they're calling  the American Psycho in this week's  episode  James shows up and Natalie is not  pleased about it you're a liar James you  weren't in Amsterdam last weekend when  Molly was killed you were in London I am  paying you a fortune to fix this now fix  it grace attends Molly's memorial even  though she knows she's not supposed to  even grace to her own devices she  grabbed a shovel and starts digging her  own grave  back a mole with this girl and we find  out who has Molly cellphone we have to  find Molly's phone before someone else  does it's a great episode this week  you're not gonna want to miss it to knit  when I get my hands on whoever killed  her I promise you before they die  they're going to suffer  you